it's 9:00 a.m. at a building site on the
edge of the Moldovan capital kishi now
20 young people have come from all over
the world to build a house together
Gordon booster from the German nonprofit
organization build and grow explains
that the builders are actually business
professionals who are working to help
poor families here I often see the
emptiness and in a dissatisfaction of my
colleagues who devise strategies but
never get to see the end result this
project is completely different here the
team works towards a common goal and
changes lives Vista is 26 years old and
works as a business consultant for an
international company over the past year
he's already built one house together
with his colleagues and a Moldovan
construction company the company is
called único walls and specializes in a
particularly energy-efficient prefab
building system the young firm is a
so-called social business 10% of their
building projects and houses are for
socially disadvantaged people Anna told
melancia is one of the founders the way
we built approximately we make this
homes at least 75% more efficient than
traditional home building existing in
Moldova and yeah I think we can
contribute to this climate let's say
change initiatives and also protect our
environment our woods and even even do
less import from other countries
most housing blocks in Moldova were
built during Soviet times the insulation
is poor or in some cases non-existent in
the winter time the heating costs eat up
about a third of a normal income those
who managed to put a little money aside
retrofit insulation to their apartments
but the Mustafa family can't afford it
they have two children their son Adrian
is severely disabled and requires
round-the-clock parental care no dream
doesn't we live on the first floor and
here is often very cold
by contrast those on the fifth floor
nearly die of heat in the summer spring
on the first and top floor there are
always problems roof leaks or you're
plagued by cockroaches mice and bedbugs
because the cellars too cold now the
most of us will be moving into the new
house that's currently being assembled
by the business professionals their tiny
apartment isn't really suited to a
disabled person's needs but the most of
us won't only have a new home Alexandra
who is an artist and designer will have
a new job too the coastal tongue can 3/8
in the future I'll be working as a
consultant for única walls I have some
ideas about different ways that one can
build the facade to avoid well-trodden
designs and attract a more exclusive
clientele but not too complicated I
think they could make good use of the
individual components of the new house
are made in a factory in the country's
Northwest Alexandra Mustafa has come
here to see which facades the company
offers so far
each house is unique the design of the
Mustapha family's home also originated
on a computer here the most important
building material is timber the company
uses the leftover scraps for firewood
what you see behind me is the raw wood
that we import or we either buy from
Moldova we cut it to exact size for our
panels all the rest of the wood is used
to heat up this entire home each panel
consists of a wooden frame which is then
filled with polystyrene sheets it's a
plastic but it's unbeatable in terms of
weight and density then the panel is
sealed with fire proof and waterproof
sheeting a tree on volnek and his
colleagues from unique ax are keen to
pass on their expertise so they hold
regular lectures at Moldova's Technical
University the University which is
training up the engineers of tomorrow
has made energy supply and efficiency
one of its core themes the situation is
not that good right now because Moldova
depends only on one country in terms of
gas and
petrol on Russia and for us it's very
important to diversify such sources it's
day three on the construction site and
the house is standing now it's time to
fit the windows the basic construction
cost fifty thousand euros a part of that
was financed by donations from the
volunteer workers in two hours the keys
will be handed over the insulation and
waterproofing still have to be added to
the roof everyone is going hammer and
tongs to get it finished I think it's
totally cool that I can stay in Europe
and say okay I'm gonna work on this
project I know where my money is going
in the evening it's time for the big
moment the Mustafa family are given the
keys to their new home then it's time to
celebrate meanwhile the family can now
inspect their new rooms it's been such a
wonderful day
I feel great really great ever since I
met my husband we dreamed of one day
owning our own home now that dream is a
reality it's all a bit overwhelming just
super some of the team want to take part
in the next house building project too
and make another family happy
[Music]